Vamos como ciclismo porque estamos a
menos de una semana ya de que comience
el Tour de Francia la ronda gana parte
del próximo sábado desde Bilbao en
España y todo indica que será otra vez
una lucha entre Jonas bingleger el
vigente campeón de Dinamarca y eres nota
de hipo gacha defensor de dos coronas en
esta carrera para hablar de la previa de
este tour nos acompaña Tatiana Rodríguez
periodista del diario Colombia
bienvenida Tatiana Gracias Juan un
placer como siempre vamos a ver de nuevo
una lucha cabeza entre Jonas binglegard
y tadepogatha Cher tienen rivales para
este tour pues Juan yo creo que
definitivamente no hay duda que de que
son los principales favoritos tanto el
danés como el esloveno
pogachar ha hecho 10 competencias este
año ha ganado siete de ellas
bingle ha corrido un poco menos ha hecho
cuatro y ha ganado tres en la única que
se vieron las caras este año fue en la
París Niza y en esa pogacha le ganó el
Duelo a vinegor quedó primero y el danés
quedó tercero y yo creo que los vamos a
volver a ver de nuevo en ese Duelo ya
han tenido dos duelos en el de Francia
este va a ser el tercero el de este año
iba a ser algo muy fundamental y muy
importante los equipos para cada uno
tanto el Jumbo como el uae van a ser
importantes este año no va a estar
roglish con bingevard Pero sí va a tener
pues van a ver que es uno de los mejores
ciclistas del mundo y uno de los mejores
gregarios además va a contar también con
christoflaport que ha tenido un buen año
en este 2023 Y seguramente contará
también con sepús que va a repetir
después de su participación en el giro y
binglegard mejor no se queda atrás su
equipo también es bastante competitivo
va a tener hamaca va a estar con Soler
va a estar con Adam yates que
seguramente lo van a ayudar entonces
creo que los dos van a tener ahí pues un
buen Duelo nuevamente es lo que vamos a
ver este año los otros candidatos Los
favoritos yo creo que están un escalón
más abajo que ellos creo que no van a
darles la pelea tan fuerte como como
todos esperaríamos para que haya un poco
más de competencia pero creo que no creo
que
que va a ser un duelo de los dos pero
podríamos nombrar algunos yo creo que
podemos nombrar a David gaudú del
grupama el francés que pues ha tenido
bastantes oportunidades de su equipo es
tiene un mucho talento pero yo creo que
todavía le falta ese empujón ese no sé
si es empujón para llegar algo más
tenemos también a mikel Landa delbaré en
Victorius tenemos a Freddy también el
británico de compañero de Landa Y por
qué no nombrar también a Tomás pitcot
delineos y a Juliana la philippe del
soudal también podrían completar digamos
eso Los favoritos para este año esa
pregunta
que es un jugador es un ciclista que lo
veremos a ver qué tal Qué tal Bien se
maneja liderando a un equipo como una
carrera como el Tour de Francia vamos a
hablar de los latinoamericanos porque no
se augura que tengamos una presencia muy
importante de ciclistas de la región
Cuáles serían las cartas Aunque falta
todavía por por conocer las listas de
algunos equipos Cuáles son las cartas de
los ciclistas de la región para ese Tour
de Francia sí como usted lo dice Todavía
falta conocer la escuadra que va a
formar el ineos Pero lo más seguro es
que van a estar egan Bernal y Daniel
Felipe Martínez sobre egan creo que pues
lo dejan es muy positivo hace apenas año
y medio que tuve el accidente y está muy
cerca de correr otra vez al Tour de
Francia entonces creo que está bien Creo
que las carreras que ha hecho ha tenido
un poco de mala suerte y también digamos
la mentalidad Y esa inseguridad que el
mismo reconoce todavía no están bien no
lo tienen como ese ciclista que veíamos
antes
ha hecho buenas carreras este año ha
tenido algunas caídas pero yo creo que
lo que vimos en romandía en Hungría y
también en el criterio del delfíné nos
hacen pensar que ha tenido una buena
recuperación él en este momento está en
Mónaco haciendo su preparación llevando
sus números al límite y creo que que
sería muy bueno poder verlo de nuevo en
el Tour de Francia en donde también
podría estar su compañero Daniel Felipe
Martínez y lo que usted dice no hay un
no hay un líder que podamos decir pero
este va a ser el líder del equipo
británico está el español Carlos
Rodríguez está el británico Thomas
pitcock vamos a ver si de pronto Daniel
Felipe le dan esa oportunidad Aunque lo
que vimos en el criterio del delfíneno
fue muy bueno sobre todo en esa última
etapa y con respecto a bueno Rigoberto
urán creo que es el único que tenemos
confirmado hasta este momento que va a
estar en el Tour y con respecto a los
otros latinos sí va a ser Va a tener muy
poca participación este año
latinoamérica El otro es Richard carapaz
que este año pues está corriendo en el
education First no ha tenido buenos
resultados en este en este año ha
corrido poco está recuperándose Y
seguramente Rigoberto urán va a ser su
gregario al parecer viene con unas
molestias médicas que retrasaron su
temporada y por eso tiene eso Tatiana
para terminar rápidamente nos alejamos
un poco del tour tuvimos un campeonato
nacionales en Europa que nos dejan esos
campeonatos a una semana del Tour de
Francia sí se corrieron esta semana
tanto ruta como contrarreloj con
resultados bastante interesantes sobre
todo pensando en el Tour de Francia nada
más en Países Bajos tuvimos a Dylan van
barley que va a ser uno de los
compañeros de Jonas binguer tuvimos
también a Fred wright que fue campeón en
Inglaterra a Valentín madua que también
va a ser parte del grupo ama en el Tour
campeón de Francia
y Bueno creo que son corredores que
podrían pues estar también en la pelea y
pues el gran campeón en eslovenia que no
tiene ningún tipo de rival Por supuesto
que fue taipo gacha ganando tanto la
contrarreloj como la carrera de la ruta
y vimos también a baud van a ver no que
ganó ganó la contrarreloj en Bélgica y
dos corredores que creo que vale la pena
destacar no van a estar en el Tour de
Francia Pero uno es la revelación del
ciclismo de este año que es el Irlandés
benjili que que ganó en su país y el
otro Pues es rencool que se coronó en
Bélgica tremendo lugar
de su país diciendo el mayor de campeona
del mundo un juego con muchísimo futuro
y ya una realidad del ciclismo Tatiana
Muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en deportes domingo vale
Juan Muchas gracias Un placer como
siempre